最近、髪の毛を切ったんですけど。
長さは変わっていないんですよ。
長さは変わってないんだけど
僕、髪の毛の量が多いのでメチャクチャ少なくしてもらったんですけど。
結果的にほぼハゲてしまいました。
ちょっとワックスをつけて、頑張って盛ってます。
はじめしゃちょーです！
皆は日常的に何を飲むかな？
僕はですね、今年から、お菓子、ジュース、禁止してるんで
僕はお菓子、ジュース飲んだり  食べたり  できないんで
僕が飲めるものと言ったら必然的に
水、お茶、でも両方、僕、嫌いなんだ
基本的には炭酸水しか飲まないんですけども
今日はチョットお茶の勉強をしようと思いまして
世の中にはたくさんのお茶がある
様々なお茶が世の中にはたくあんあるが、
違いもちょっとよくわかんないんだ
そんな僕が今日、特殊なお茶をちょっと四つほど見つけたんで
実際どんな味なのかも良く分かんないんで、買ってきたお茶を紹介しようと思います
今日で死ぬかもしれないな
先ずはこちら、あー苦虫茶。
苦い、のポジションですね。苦虫の味がするみたいです
ホントにこんな感じなのかな
マグマ茶。これは「辛い」ですね
ｼﾞｮﾛｷｱ？まって、ｼﾞｮﾛｷｱってヨロシクなくね？
ｼﾞｮﾛｷｱの激辛を超えてるらしいです
もう、お茶かどうかも怪し…
靴下茶。ぅわーこれは酷そうですね
お父さんの靴下を一気に飲む感じらしいです
そしてラストはこちら、これは臭い、ドブ茶。
かわいそうに。口の中にザリガニや鯉が飼われてますね。
ザリガニ臭
はい、と言う訳でこちらの四つです。この四つを今日は、一つのお茶にまとめてグイッと飲んでみようと思います
世界一臭い物も食ったし
ものすげ辛い物も食った
これから四つが掛かってきてパッと来ても
多分僕は大ジョブだと思います
では早速作って見ましょ、ではイコ！
ティーバックひと包みをカップに入れ、お湯を注ぎ、1，2分ほど蒸らしてからお飲み下さい
1，2分らしいです
ドブ、マグマ、苦虫、靴下
この四つのティーバックを一気に入れて、2分間待ちましょ
そうすると！
酸っぱくて、苦くて、辛く、て臭い　お茶が出来るらしいです
1人で全部の罪を背負ってる
これはｱﾚか、臭いやつか？
いや？ そんなに、
あ、なんか、後から来るわ
これが、ドブ茶です。
ジョロ級より辛いつったらもう、下手したらデスソースとかの上を行くレベルっすよ
首が、無くなる臭いだった
これってね、ドンキに売ってたからさ
そんな、メチャクチャ、厳しいって訳でもない気がするんですけども、
普通の、茶葉なんだよね
こっちはそんなに・・・最後に、酸っぱい、靴下茶。
靴下の匂いすんのかなぁ　　そんな事ってある？
靴下茶。
あ、あ、あ、お、あこれ、友達の靴下の臭いだ
俺の友達の靴下の臭いがする、これ
これ絶対、 だいち君の臭いだ、 これ絶対だいち君の臭いする。   大地君の靴下の臭いだ。 これ絶対だいち君の靴下の臭い
これ、だいち君入ってんの？
あ！これだいち君の靴下の臭いだ。絶対だいち君作ったっしょ、これ、
だいち君、ふざけんな
オッケー　　ではこれで二分ほど待ちまちょう
大地君の靴下入ってる
おおっ　もう多分10分ぐらい待ちました
底が、見えなくなりました
これぐらいやんなきゃダメだろ、男は
はい、と言う訳で完成しました。
ドブ＆苦虫＆靴下＆マグマ茶です
この、四つのコンテンツをまとめた、言わゆる、マルチプレイヤーです、素晴らしい
まぁ、今後はね多分野の知識を詰め込んだ人がね、ま、成功するんすよ、間違いない。
ひとつの事だけできるんじゃなくね？こう多彩な力が
今後の社会に求められます
風味は、風味は普通です
大地君の靴下どこ行った？
あ、埋もれちゃったのかな。靴下の臭いは無くなってますね
でわ、早速飲んでみようと思います。乾杯。
マジだ！マジなヤツだ・・・まってまてまて
うぉこれ、すごいな
待って、これ凄い、ガチだ
飲もう！取りあえず飲みます、全部
男は、、飲むんだよ！！！
人には感情がある。
嬉しい。
悲しい。
辛い。
悔しい。
彼の感情は・・・
限界だった・・・
空気がおいしい
あれ？目の前が凄い。
目の前がチラつきがするよ？
わ、これ、凄いわ。
あの、ちょっと舐めてましたね。
辛いし、苦いし、・・・酸っぱいのは、解んなかった
あ・・これ、あれだ絶対真似しない方が良いﾔﾂこれマジでホントに
失敗した。皆さん炭酸水を飲みましょう。ｼﾞｬな！